his production supervisor are angry
bibarovic is a bosniak who works for the
food production business akova impacts
one of its biggest products is chicken
pate the company is one of the biggest
employers in bosnia but now its new
factory is standing idle
the 10 million euro facility was meant
to boost exports to neighboring croatia
but since july business has come to a
crashing halt
it was a growing business and we all
every day even now we're seeing the
emails from their customers asking what
happened to your chicken i don't have
your products anymore it was great
product was a good price
but
i don't know what transfer them croatia
joined the eu in july
now it's subject to import regulations
especially on food europe insists on
common state controls for consumer
protection with all its trading partners
including bosnia our government
didn't make possible didn't prepare
everything didn't prepare papers didn't
prepare stamp that will guarantee that
our product is ready for european union
that's that's why
sarajevo the bosnian capital
the country is home to bosniaks croats
and serbs
and ethnic divisions still remain 18
years after the end of the war
but do bosnia's wrangling politicians
plan to ignore rules that apply to 500
million consumers in the eu and risk
damaging businesses in their own country
we try and find out
liubamir kalaba a serb is the director
of bosnia's state veterinary office he's
in charge of stamping exports that meet
eu standards
but he says he can't
oh
of course we should have begun work a
few years ago
but laws in bosnia-herzegovina have to
be approved by the serbian and bosniak
croat representatives
and all of this complicates the
situations
so it's all about chicken products
needing documentation for export to the
eu
and it's the farmers who are worst hit
abdullah tutmich is a bosniak who breeds
poultry that supplies the pate factory
he's frustrated
we farmers work as hard as we can but
the state institutions simply don't do
their job
the farmers feel they're getting a raw
deal tutmich says he recently tried to
get state subsidies for his farm he says
he spoke to a party official in the
agricultural ministry who spelled out
the terms in a written agreement
it says here you'll get your money if
you divert half the funds to the party
the other half will be yours and from
that i would have had to pay 15 to the
middle man
a clear case of corruption
but tutmich rejected the offer and
instead built his new chicken breeding
facility without state money
in the village a neighbor approaches to
mitch
here try some fresh blueberries
six euros for the whole pail
it's possible to live without corruption
we take tutmich's claims to the
agriculture minister of the bosniak
croat federation the croat denies the
whole thing
people are accusing me to discredit my
work
but these allegations have gone nowhere
because i've made everything transparent
but what about the export problems
we could solve this problem in a day
the cabinet and the parliament could
pass laws to that effect within a day
but there's no political will to do that
and then the minister shows us a
campaign carried out by his ministry
last year
it's for homegrown products like the
ones his own companies conveniently sell
especially in the bosnia croat region
these ethnic differences aren't as
visible here in the picturesque bosnian
countryside
there's a serbian flag here that's
important to vladimir uzorach
the dairy farmer has 80 cows and
automated milking facilities
but his stalls are half empty
and there are problems with milk exports
to croatia just 50 kilometers away
of course it's a problem that our
politicians don't manage to meet
conditions
but the european union does not force
them to do that either
so should the eu do the work that
bosnia's ethnically divided people and
wrangling politicians can't so that
bosnian farmers can continue to export
to new eu member state croatia
it sounds like a far-fetched hope
ned said
the bosniak food production manager
isn't optimistic that things will change
anytime soon
there's no war here anymore we have
fights in
politics i mean we still have two or
three sides
people that want to live together people
that doesn't want to leave to live
together it's very
difficult to find compromise and
set everybody ready for new future
a new future free from ethnic and
political divisions and the tensions
they provoke still seems a distant dream
in bosnia-herzegovina